remotely created his mythology the ring
as a response I guess to what Nietzsche
called to the death of God which was the
god of the Torah now Leah for you being
a religious you I know you're religious
you what is the difference what is the
difference between a world in which your
god of the Torah is still present and
this reckon Aryan world with the gods of
the era well in terms of there's a lot
to be said about this that's the first
thing I'd say is that in terms of the
sublimity of the god concept I mean I'm
one of those people who believes that
whatever the word God means it has to
mean something
sublime and we can discuss what that
means to but they compared to the ADA
well I mean compared to the to the
highest expression of the concept of God
in the monotheistic traditions the ADA
are fairytales and they are filled they
may be of narrative interest literary
interest human interest psychological
interest but they are of no metaphysical
or philosophical interest at least to me
I think that there are two ways to think
about the death of God the death of God
when people speak that way they're
either speaking about culture or about
philosophy it's true you know that that
there were came a point in Western
culture when faith began to wane and if
you want to call the decline of faith
the death of God it's kind of a
melodramatic and somewhat narcissistic
way to put it but fine you know I
arrived when I first read that famous
sentence in it in the gay science of
Nietzsche is about the death of God I
thought to myself well you lost your
faith so God dies I mean that seems
awfully narcissistic to me but
culturally there's no question that
secularization was one of the
fundamental forces that created the
modern world and the people began to
lose
faith not just in God but in the
metaphysical dimension more generally
more generally and that's still to my
mind a huge problem then there is the
question of the death of God
philosophically and that really is
question of what is true or false about
the universe you know the difference
between the ancient and medieval view on
the one hand and the modern view of
religion on the other hand was that in
the old view religion was before it was
anything else a series of propositions
about the universe that were either true
or false there is a God there is no God
there is Providence there is chance the
world was created matter is eternal they
can't all be right and that's why
science was very involved in this kind
of religion the modern view of religion
is that religion is not about objective
truth so much as about what we call
subjective truth and it's about
Interstates ecstasy and fear and
trembling and dread and sickness unto
death and bliss and etc etc but one of
the things if if one takes religion
seriously one of the first things one
realizes is that the intensity of a
belief and the popularity of a belief
have nothing whatsoever to do with the
truth of a belief nothing nothing so for
example I recognize that people have
martyred themselves the causes and given
down their life that they believed in
it's so intensely that they're gave they
gave their life but I happen to think
that what they gave their life for is
nonsense that doesn't mean I don't
respect them because they made it
there's a great spiritual achievement in
that but philosophically speaking the
idea that God dies is completely
incoherent you know the there's what
when we were in high school we were
given Elie Wiesel --zz night to read and
in night there is the famous sentence in
which he says I forget the words that
God died at Auschwitz and I remember
thinking even then wait a second if
there is a God then God didn't die at
Auschwitz he wasn't born
doesn't die that that that and the only
way for me to read that sentence and
maybe the only way for me to read
Nietzsche sentence is not as an
expression of of philosophy but as an
expression of feeling which is to say
that they experienced such loneliness
and desolation in the universe that the
world became so cold and so unbearable
that the only way they could formulate
this feeling was to say that god is dead
but so I think y'all stop here but I
think that generally you have to
distinguish between the cultural
phenomenon of the loss of faith and the
actual question of what we have
justified grounds in believing they're
not the same question even if you can
prove to anyone satisfaction that God
does exist that still may have no impact
whatsoever on the progress of
secularization in culture and the loss
of interest in metaphysics and so on so
I think that's the distinction you have
to be
you